would you advise
artists to take a big advance when they
do
uh sign a deal or do any sort of
distribution or would you advise them to
like
because you know at the end of the day
you got to pay that money back two times
to
to break even on it for the most part
would you advise somebody to take a big
bag because i think a lot of people are
like yo i signed this
million dollar deal yeah but it's like
was it worth you like taking that
upfront money to just like
yeah you could or you could just get the
monthly yeah
it depends on your situation at the
moment though like you know it says you
are
if you coming like right now if somebody
come off me a million dollars
right now for for record deal i know
i'm not going to take it because you can
do that yeah because i i can see the
amount of money i'm making
i see you know saying that what i'm
getting
from the people that i'm messing with
right now without even having to commit
so much you know what i'm saying like
yeah do something with empire you could
do whatever you want yeah you feel me so
it's like
if you really know the game
somebody like empire gonna be your best
bit and i ain't just saying they're
gonna sign an empire
right if you know the game because like
i say i say this in every interview
if you just through watch your time a
major i want to say another sign to a
major label
if that's what it takes to get on your
feet as an artist do that sometimes you
gotta do what you gotta do yeah do what
you gotta do but while you in that deal
be listening learning what they do
making the connections that you know
saying when you mean people don't just
you know saying really meet people like
when you meet people they be introducing
you or you'll be around the people that
they hiring to
do this stuff so if you meet them people
once you do go independent you got a
good relationship
you kind of have an idea of an
infrastructure yeah you know
a lot of times they're going to charge
you way cheaper than what they ch what
they're doing
hey what you just said is like a lost
art form in the music game
and that's these like i mean i see it as
like being on the radio side like
you'll meet an artist and you'll be like
damn that dude does not want to be here
like he's like a dick like you could
tell he's just like
yeah you know and and the thing is is
like that's fine yeah but like
building like genuine relationships and
like like you said when you meet
somebody like meet him don't be like yo
what's up fam yeah
because you never like you you never
know when you might you know what i'm
saying it'd probably be a
it'd probably be a little reporter that
was like you probably go somewhere
you probably had a intern in here you
know what i'm saying uh
five years from now who could that be
yeah yeah that intern can be somebody or
that intern can be he he could be the
the the lead writer for this person i've
seen that [ __ ] happen all the time i
mean
i used to i was an intern for two years
working for free yeah it's like they're
gonna remember if you
you know they're gonna remember that if
you know saying hi respectful of the
artist you was you know saying that they
genuinely
[ __ ] with you when they when they met
you type stuff like that so i'll be
keeping all that in mind like when i
meet people you know so i i actually i
genuinely
[ __ ] with people so uh i feel like just
throughout my career like
every everybody that i've met like i met
shirley wrote a lot when i was
signed with columbia you know what i'm
saying we just spoke briefly and stuff
like that but
uh you know once i got independent you
know i still had no relationships to
be able to you know saying go back and
politic
water and stuff like that so now that
i'm independent i'm just moving way
way different i really feel like way
more
freer like it's a different piece of
mind they put you in a different music
space like
i can really drop whenever i want like
you know what i'm saying and that's
like i could take it on the drop or i
could drop back to back it's however i
want to do whatever you want to do
so it's just a different space man then
a lot of times like i said if you don't
make the connection they don't the
labels gonna kill you with them over
here it's like you're gonna be wondering
like
oh yeah you're gonna be like why did i
pay yo the worst part i see
is i see like like i have had friends
signed and then
they'll get like an engineering fee for
making the clean version of their album
and it'll be like fifteen thousand
dollars
yeah like wait i paid some dude fifteen
grand to make the clean version of my
single like nobody's charging like
that's insane
but like you said like you just gotta
know anything you gotta be smart you got
no ways to filter that money though
also like you know a lot of artists like
they'll they'll like let the student
like the the label pick their studio and
then like you look and they're like wait
i spent two grand today in
studio time when i could have went and
like booked my own spot for like five
hundred dollars
yeah see i recorded my own i recorded
all like all my
songs i got plex and stuff i recorded
mixed and messed with all my own stuff
so
you you record mix master everything
yeah yeah i do i do everything
now i don't you know what i'm saying
right right right oh my passed up
i did you just recording it everything
at home yeah i've recorded everything
like what's your like home setup like
you know what was your mic like
you know what's in the yamaha speakers
right the the just the basement
yeah the bait the basically a padded
room the basic stuff you know what i
said it's
all really about your your presets and
like i said i had a template you get
that little template the engineer put
you on that template yeah that engineer
he put me on my tent he put me on that
template so
like what i was doing i was just
charging them for me recording myself so
that's how you filter out your recording
budget you probably got a 150 recording
budget you know what i'm saying if you
record yourself
you know what i'm saying that's right
they're not in the studio more artists
should open their own studios
that's how you just gotta know your
contract though if you don't know your
country
especially you like if you ever like i
know are you gonna end up
trying i got an artist yeah i got yeah i
got an art i got an artist right now uh
name uh brooklyn love i had another
artist before that but she
i uh i don't really mess with everyone
but i got an artist right now named
brooklyn love she uh she's
dope yeah now she's from uh baltimore oh
[ __ ] be more
uh-huh that's wild shout out to
baltimore man